we can either buy them you can become
water and then you add spices so if you
want to put them in a pan with garlic
and olive oil it's also option and we
will also prepare some fish kamila what
you put is bechamel ah
so it's a very similar physical beat not
Jamis Kaka whatever I was thinking is
that for the cracks I would like each of
you to have a chance to cook their own
crackers so maybe like two of you can
provide the butter bean pasta and then
everybody can make a few cramps right
then another group is making the
spillages Camilla Camilla is very very
simple because what we will do you take
you take a pendulum a pot take a little
bit of butter
melt when you add a little bit of flour
when it starts to be fighting that when
it starts to be light brown then you add
warm milk I will give the right
proportions and then you mix it till it
gets back to one and then it's gonna be
ready within a few minutes yes this is
so for Nyjah we want to vomit and garlic
cut the fontina in a small pieces and we
want to grate it parmigiano because this
is what we will do we prepare the
crespella
then in each crespella inside is
crespella we will put some bechamel a
sauce mix of the two cheeses and spinach
then you fall down in your favorite
shape and then we put them in in latakia
a lotta yeah back in for not necks or no
in the oven
and they gave us to make better not to
speak
okay so we'll make them small this very
well you can you can remember or we can
make triangles and then just put them
side by side
potato yeah the other key part when you
make crepes is that you want to be
harder to be smooth
you must create this new row and then
you are sixteen flower
okay so when we were going to do we take
10 feet of water medium heat the butter
is melted you take put it you want to
assure that so you can rotate on the
bottom of latavia okay then you take the
crap you put some much bigger cheese and
then we close everything and we can even
gonna show you but okay this is one
option and then we put it like this or
yeah do you think that's enough I mean I
like
awesome awesome Tony Seeman so delicious